tonight's congressional hearing with
secretary of state anthony blanken was
supposed to get to the bottom of biden's
awful afghanistan evacuation but that
didn't happen blanket is a massive
dodging question so we didn't get many
answers however one thing did happen
congressman scott perry went off script
and asked the secretary of state about
hunter biden watch
how long was your recent interview with
the fbi and was it a deposition
i'm sorry i don't know what you're
referring are you saying that you have
not had a recent interview with the fbi
since becoming secretary of state
i'm
i
i'm not sure what you're referring to
and i'm happy to take that up with you
offline did the state department turn
over documents to the fbi related to
hunter biden barisma
and or the blue state strategies
corporation
uh you'll
have to uh so you have no knowledge of
this you have had no you don't you are
you saying you have not had an interview
with the fbi it would not be appropriate
for me to comment uh in a public forum
on any uh legal proceedings that the
department i'm not asking you to comment
about i'm not asking you to comment on
the legal proceedings i'm just asking if
you've been interviewed by the fbi since
becoming secretary of state
um again i'm not going to comment one
way or another on any uh legal
proceedings or not uh that may or may
not have happened
you saw it let me remind the gentleman
that the topic of this hearing is
afghanistan that's what we are i
appreciate it mr chairman but secretary
generally refuses to answer questions
about afghanistan so i just figured we'd
talk about something you should be
intimately familiar with have you sought
to alter any of your testimony from last
year's senate investigation regarding
this topic mr secretary general's time
has expired
the man asking those questions was
congressman scott perry of pennsylvania
and he is now to react congressman uh it
is very clear the secretary of state was
caught off guard uh he was stumbling so
what was where were you getting that
right there why did you choose that line
of questioning what do you know
well lawrence first of all thank you
very much it's better to offer no excuse
than a series of bad excuses and that
hearing certainly proves to the american
people that we have a poor excuse for
secretary of state and an even worse one
for president of the united states but
with that being said listen um what
we're trying to do is
obviously blinking is well coached he
wouldn't come in person he's on video so
he can he can pre-script all the
questions we can't he you know the pre
the screen goes dark uh when when when
when we're talking so he has time to see
our questions and hear our questions and
then get an answer from his advisors
before he actually answers and he wasn't
going to answer any questions
realistically on the horrific failure of
afghanistan so i thought i'd talk to him
about something that i knew was reported
that he had had conversations with the
fbi and that potentially they called him
back in because something's not matching
up regarding his relationship uh with
hunter biden when he was assistant
secretary of state i think it's
something that the american people ought
to know i question the secretary of
state's judgment and and his credibility
regarding afghanistan and everything
else and the fact that he's had a close
relationship with hunter biden when he
was assistant secretary of state
regarding events in ukraine that's very
concerning to the american people
i want to slow you down for a second
because i think this is important for
the audience to know are you saying that
you know for a fact that he met
with the fbi regarding his relationship
with hunter biden what do you know
specifically about that
well that's the report i'm getting but i
think that the press quite honestly
ought to ask him like i asked him and he
wouldn't answer i can't confirm it i'm
not in the fbi and i'm not secretary
blinken there's one guy that can prefer
that that can confirm it and that's
secretary anthony blinken do you know
anything about the relationship between
hunter biden and the secretary because a
lot of americans are trying to figure
out why is he contacting the deputy
secretary of state will he be would he
be able to do that if he wasn't joe
biden's son what is the reason for that
connection
well there are emails out there in open
source that show the conversation was
not about as as i understand it uh what
anthony blinken said which was beau
baton i don't think they're about beau
biden i think they're about issues of
ukraine and other maybe projects that
hunter biden was working on and that's
per the emails that are already are you
suggesting it was barisma
i i can't suggest anything i i i want
the secretary of state uh you know he
wants to talk to me offline i suggest he
talks to the american people and let all
of us know what he was talking about has
he called it has he called you
congressman because he talked about that
in the hearing that he was willing to
talk offline so has there been any
coordination between your office to sit
down with the secretary to get some
answers to that because he didn't want
the american people to hear about that
today no he did not you could tell by
the look on his face he didn't deny it
right but uh uh but he hasn't called me
about it maybe he's calling you lawrence
but he hasn't talked to me about it
do you plan on reaching back to his
office since he said under oath today
that he was willing to do that do you
plan on reaching out to his office to
get those answers
we certainly do but here again lawrence
it's important not only that members of
congress
remember we're just representatives of
the people the important thing is that
the people have this information we need
to know whether this guy is credible
what is whether his judgment is sounded
just remember he just presided he and
president uh president biden presided
over the worst foreign policy and
national security failure in united
states history i think there's reason to
question everything that he's been
involved in congressman why did your
chairman cut you off in the middle of
that that hearing because it seemed like
when you were getting into the facts of
of the story and he started to shuffle a
little bit that the chairman jumped in
is that procedure in the house
well what's procedure is by democrats
and you look they all close ranks no
matter how horrific the policy is 13
dead marines america being you know our
reputation being dragged across the
world stage they all close ranks and and
do whatever is necessary to support the
failed policy and their president joe
biden they don't care about the american
people they care about the power that
they have and they're not going to let
anybody assail their
their secretary has stayed you know on
an open mic so yeah he just had to cut
it off congressman thanks so much for
coming on we're going to keep digging
into the story hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else